Now special relativity is really an amazing subject.
For me, when I took special relativity, this was the first time that I encountered something
that was completely unintuitive, and by that, I mean the conclusions which we're going to draw
from special relativity are going to be things we never see in our daily lives.
And that's because special relativity deals with the realms of the very, very fast
of objects moving near the speed of light.
The speed of light is such as important number in physics that we give it own variable.
We call it lowercase c and it's value is about 3x10â¸ m/s.
In fact the exact value is 299,792,458 m/s,
but this is the approximation we're going to be using in this unit.
All right, so I have told you how crazy and mind blowing this topic is going to be.
Where do we begin such a topic? Who do we start with? What do we talk about?
Well, let's start with our good friend Galileo.
Now you may have heard that special relativity is Einstein's theory, Albert Einstein,
and yes that's true, but just like Newton before him, Einstein stood on the shoulders of Galileo
to make his or at least one of his amazing discoveries.
In fact, his theory of special relativity can be completely derived by 2 postulates.
A postulate or axiom is just something that we believe to be true and which we use.
We use these postulates by applying logic to them and eventually we get some conclusions.
That's pretty amazing about this approach to problems is that as long as the logic is sound,
you can't argue the conclusions if you believe the postulates.
What I'm going to do today is show you what these two postulates are.
Motivate why they must be true then we'll see a couple of the remarkable conclusions that follow.
Let's move forward to the first postulate.